[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lun
fils essaie de me comprendre Je Ne sais
j'ai passé un bon moment
prendre et puis c'est pacile
Je vais vous dire comment mettre en évidence après quelques
Années qu'à perdu fils
sourire bien qu'elle ait gardé sa
beauté ton m'as Vu Plus souvent
part qut pour te
réveiller mon
fils tu sais dans l'existence IL y a des
des différences qui sont désormais à toi
apprendre
c'est jamais noir ou blanc mais d'un
gris
différentes polices dans les reflets dans le
s sur sadora puiss sans
Je comprendrai on oublie ce qu'on s'est
promis et puis un jour l'enfant
grandiose
[Musique]
lun
fils Je te parle comme un homme parce
que tu es un
homme et que Moi j'ai bient TT
[Musique]
fini rien n'est fait Au hasard Je m'en
tu vas quelque part
Part essayer de refaire ma
Fri Je te verrai de temps en
temps Je penserai toi
souvent et je saurai que tu grandis
[Musique]
lun
fils essaie de me comprendre Je Ne sais
j'ai passé un bon moment
prendre et puis l'on Ne sait jamais
[Musique]
parler j'essaie de t'expliquer que tout
peut
arriver que rien d'humain n'est
éternelle même quand les sentiments s''
mais tu as appris
aussi lorsque ton fils Aura
[Musique]
super
Yo